so electron how many people have heard
electron besides good how many people
have used electron all right awesome
hopefully it won't put you to sleep the
rest of you hopefully you'll enjoy the
journey so why am I here I have a slight
mental defect I actually like standing
up here and talking to people secretly
wanting to be a teacher then I saw a
teacher pay you X software pay okay we
know her career path I recently wrote a
co-authored a book for a press with my
good friend Leif Wells on an electron
from beginner to pro actually I have a
copy here we'll figure out a raffle as
well is an interesting book we took a
different approach and writing it you
actually really don't build an app in
there how many people have I got in the
technical books and like how many people
have done in to do rewrap you know
there's real valuing to do app I'm not
going to throw that away
but there's an issue with electron that
you'll understand as we go through of
why we didn't have you build an app in
there so I'm going to teach with that
thoughts I'm still an Adobe community
professional mostly working in PhoneGap
Cordova as well as experiences I I am a
actually UX lead for a home automation
and security company down in Carlsbad so
driving north wasn't so bad it wasn't
coming from downtown San Diego I have a
cup of courses of Lynda and I've also
written a book on the ionic framework
for O'Reilly so what is electron well
ladies actually released back in 2013 so
we're talking his five year old system
where it's just about to hit the 2.0
release so it's been chugging along it
was actually written by a jinjo he
actually worked on another project
called in wjs node webpage is and then
actually moved over and then basically
it was the foundation for the atom
editor so how many people use atom okay
how many people use vyas code okay
there's a reason those are all electrons
so the idea behind electron is it's
actually a blending of technologies it's
a blend of nodejs it's a blend of
chromium which is basically the actual
engine inside of chrome the browser so
chrome is the browser of all the things
like bookmarks all that the actual web
rendering engine is chromium these two
things together are what sort of make
electron magical I was going to do the
kind of thing about dumping a lot of the
apps on your computer or probably built
with electron
I almost when I do ion and talk to Silla
same thing same things like I'll have
the apps on your phone will probably
actually written in PhoneGap you don't
know this a lot of the apps probably on
your computer are also now written in
electron so obviously atom github was
drinking their own champagne and built
the atom editor that was the foundation
of their BS code my favorite editor who
woulda thought hab I'm a little old I
got some great guests agreed like would
say yes I like a Microsoft product it's
hard to say but it isn't you know though
actually they're both great editors you
mentioned slack there's another electron
based app github desktop another one
postman if you're not familiar with that
which is a great API remote inspector
the WordPress desktop app and the list
goes on you can actually pull up that
URL and just keep scrolling all the apps
you've never heard of but it's a great
solution because it allows the
development community to again have that
one language that one set of tools and
now come to the desktop it's very
similar to almost like the sales pitch
and that I give about PhoneGap and
Cordova same idea one code base multiple
platforms so what is electron bring to
the table what does it give us as a
desktop app building solution automatic
updates so in this age agile development
and
always adding new features because there
are no bugs just new features you know
we have a way to you know push updates
to our users native menus so if you've
been doing some web app development
there are hard walls fine I have this
beautiful web app but I have the chrome
menu bar the Firefox meanwhile I have to
somehow fake some sort of interior menu
bar that's clunky kludgy doesn't fully
work right now I'm trying to hack in and
override keyboard shortcuts to try to
make no we can get that notifications
things we had that sort of an engine so
I'd say hey you know we'll use slack
slack notifications hey you just got a
new you know DM or whatever crash
reporting ok yeah there might be bugs
you might want to know about them
profiling windows installers Mac
installers on and on so it actually
brings the table a lot what you would
need in your utility built to make a
desktop app because most people don't
write desktop apps they're a rare or
breathes and say even like trying to
find someone to write a native desktop
app it's harder to find someone who like
oh can you find a swift developer can I
find a you know a a Java developer do
something for Android that's not people
will harder beauty is you can ship to
all three of the platforms so I can
write roughly with one code base ship
for the Mac ship for Windows and even
ship for those penguin love them people
out there in the world as well so and
this has a lot of value especially you
start to thinking about the enterprise
world where if you I used to work at
Qualcomm you step behind the firewall
into the land of IT and all sudden you
know here are hundreds of these web apps
and applications to make the backend
world oh wait I can start doing some
stuff that I can't do and really provide
some value so how does this all work
talked about no talk about chromium real
fast electron is really built upon to
silence it's built upon this main
process silo
and it's built upon a renderer silo
these two processes run simultaneously
and this is probably the biggest sort of
mental shift going from a web app
development world into an electron
development world because these two
friends have a way to talk to each other
but you have to explicitly tell them to
the main process that's really where
you're going to mostly interact with
that node component of electron that's
where you're gonna pull in a lot of your
node modules this is what's going to
allow you all the cool desktop stuff
that you can't do in your browser when
you start to do some browsers are
getting better but if I want to talk to
the file system right to the files
launch other applications put up native
dialogues things like that that's gonna
live over in this main process mostly
inode list of where I think it was
that's where my nodes stuff lives the
renderer process this is that UI layer
this is all living in that chrome II
inside of the world this is when I paint
on the screen to show my user something
and those are the two parts now the
interesting thing is you actually don't
have to have this part you don't have to
have a renderer you can have something
that's just a main process so if you've
got some little batch job or something
you can actually make a headless
faceless electron app and do something
with it
so let's face it we're software
developers were lazy if we can find a
way to automate a process we'll do it
and you can start doing doing things
like that you know making your life
easier that's what it's all about that
UI layer I mentioned it really briefly
it doesn't have one this is actually
sort of the hard part of electron that
is a blank web canvas just like your web
apps are you have to make some informed
decision about some framework somewhere
to come up and develop a UI later
just like Cordova Cordova is a blank
slate it doesn't care if you're using
framework seven ionic onsen your own
same thing over here so depending on
what the background you have you can
pick your technology to render that UI
layer so you know the angular people the
world a little manual or world we can
use angular if you're a react fan boom
you will play around you Joe yes great
backbone Ember heck you know if you're
old school you want to go jQuery UI you
can do that roll your own heck you can
even use ionic which I've done it's the
real challenge that's why we actually
didn't have you build an app in our book
because if I wrote a sample app to do an
angular guess who I just piss off the
reactor view people and if I did react
people I'm gonna piss the angular people
off so we actually just kept rather just
playing simple JavaScript it really
didn't go too deep because like alright
how many times so we're gonna write that
to do app and you know try to come up
with some artificial so that's the one
big challenge with electron is that UI
layer what are you gonna pick because
what you do an electron isn't
necessarily that hard said I mean you
some dialogues some things like that
it's still the hard engine as the
business logic the UI side that's where
the sort of the challenge of electron
development comes in so installing it
heck everything's NPM boom drop it real
simple now they have a little quick
little get starting and this is that
just man actually will hop out and do a
little more demos in am it basically
clone their starter has a few things
change the directory reset the get flags
npm start boom you got your initial
electron app and it looks really sexy
yeah you know hello world there's some
interesting stuff that actually goes on
actually will walk through the gets here
we'll do it here so you literally have
six files six files basically
and then the node modules start and
create my desktop application even less
because you know who cares Bethel
license we always forget which one do we
want you know do MIT whatever we have an
index.html couple JSON files and a
package JSON that's the start now in
reality you're probably gonna start you
know having directories and making
things a little nicer you know you're
probably gonna start putting
everything's I have an app folder you're
gonna have a build folder or a disk
folder things of that nature get ignore
so the main jazz so the main J's file
this is what electrons going to point to
well by default the package.json points
the main KS if you want to change
convention you can't but its main J yes
this initial javascript file is what
electrons are going to boot up from and
the nice thing is since we're living on
top of some modern stuff we can actually
start to write in a little more modern
fashion now we're gonna be writing the
main J's in j/s the renderer side you
know if you want to live over in the
land of typescript or something else you
can do that but over here you're
basically running yes thanks basically
pull an electron we define a browser
window few things like path URL
eventually we're on the call and create
a window
we say hey make me a new window when at
this height this wide
tell it what to load up in there not a
lot to it to get started
now remember it's chromium so all those
skills you have like that chrome dev
tools we have it built in is the Air
Force so everything that you kind of
have gotten used to working with as part
of that muscle memory of figuring out
starts to be there now unfortunately
because you're moving out of the browser
into a desktop app some of the
responsibilities start to move back onto
you like cleaning up after yourself when
windows closed and listening to all
these other events so some of the things
you've never had to worry about before
now become your responsibility like
going from being a teenager to like a
young adult like what do you mean I
gotta pay rent and do laundry
my twins are 17 we're in that phase so
we have a unready event so all of us who
have lived in the lands of you know
document.ready or cordoba developers
device ready we got ours yeah because
this is still gonna take you know a few
moments to boot up and things and splash
screens and you got to deal with that
world the HTML side is pretty
straightforward it's just HTML so the
nice thing is even though we're just
barely getting to 200 with electron
there's lots of little minor updates
they actually keep the chromium engine
really really really really really fresh
like within a day or two or they've
basically you got a new it so whatever
is getting poured into the latest
version of chromium in terms of support
for new features and the evolution of
you know html5 1.2 etcetera etc all the
new JavaScript is available to you a
nice thing is you're walking that inside
of your electron app so you know what
you're going to get you're not beholden
to mismatches so you could actually make
the electron even if say your enterprise
company says thou shalt use only ie or
something you know and there's it's not
as bad as it was but you know you may be
trapped in a legacy system where heaven
forbid you know they're still running
Windows 7 or something I 11 with
electron basically you have a captive
browser so you can use the new stuff
that you want to use and makes life a
whole lot easier that's a nice thing
there but you know we have our script
engine here so we have another script
engine also so we can figure out
processes so this is what actually wrote
that you hey what version of Chrome I'm
running probably I'm really my version
electron my version of node over there
real exciting and then I'm basically
pulling this render js5 so windows so
not the operating system but the actual
application window we actually have a
whole lot of parameters so out of the
box that first one just had width and
height we actually have a whole bunch of
attributes we can set up on our window
and we're not restricted to one window
I'll show an example so second windows
how to make a fake splash screen sort of
thing show you that so we can say
weather window to be shown or not our
background color we can restrict the
width and the height to the thing so you
know we can only make it so small
because as a UI person there's a point
where like yeah I know you can shrink
down the window but I can't refactor the
UI this app to that point I need a
minimum of this you know it's a data
table I can't make any smaller I can
even make it not movable so if I
actually was making some sort of you
know dashboard II think I could you know
walk all these things in positions and
not have anyone like muck them up I can
have it always be on top I can change
the title lots of capabilities I can
actually make frameless windows so if I
don't want the window chrome I don't
have to have the window chrome I can
also make my window transparent if I
want it to that was a lot of fun that
was an interesting one I don't know if
anyone has used this I don't know what's
written in but I've seen some web
measurement apps that you can fire up
and it will act as overlays on top of
the browser you're trying
take screen measurements and that sort
of thing that's what you could use this
potentially for yeah so here's a
transparent one so yeah there's a
attribute transparent true if I plan be
transparent I'd see this stuff through
this the content in the HTML is there
but the window itself is transparent so
you can do interesting things mention
this earlier menus this is obviously one
of the big differentiators between the
browser world in the desktop world and
when you launch any sort of application
you have a menu bar that has all the
things that you want to do with it not
what chrome wants to do what Firefox
wants to do we have that capability and
this is actually what usually winds up
with being the bigger blocks of code in
my electron apps because you have to
define all those menu items and the
structure and it becomes something about
this long ten times longer for a fully
fledged menu so basically we tell it to
build from a template we set the
application menu and away we go
what does that template look like well
is basically a big long nested message
JSON file so we give label and the first
label that's what scrolling across the
top of the menu bar and then the sub
menus are the things underneath and you
have sub menus in there and infinitum ad
in front now you can update this on the
fly you can change what things are
enabled so everything you think you need
to do with the menu you can do it's not
a hack now what's nice is they have both
accelerators and roles because when
you're stepping into the land of the
desktop world there are lots of
conventions you know cut copy paste
etcetera etc you don't need to rewrite
those they understand that those are
sort of core functionality and that's
where that role comes at so they sort of
automatically handled that for
by adding that role they know what you
want to do yeah you can't overwrite it
so if you put that in your you basically
have a contract with electron that this
is how it's going to work so you have
something custom you're gonna have to
call your own function but we can also
define our accelerators those are the
keyboard shortcuts and you'll see you
that first one you know command or
control hey I can deliver to both
platforms I'll smack people it's you
know commands see the windows vote says
control see it handles both of those
worlds for you it knows what OS it's
running on and will adapt to that so
here's an example screenshot of a a menu
being instantiated so there are you know
my modifier is up there here's a submenu
I have a checkmark under there all that
is within my electron control so as I'm
moving things in and around I can do all
that contention once how many people try
to do a contextual menu in their web app
the latter - yeah it was fun wasn't it
yeah yeah you just it was probably the
most happiest things you'd ever attempt
and yeah and you still probably got JIRA
tickets from QA saying it didn't work
yeah yeah yeah so we get them as well so
this is just basically another variation
of the menu element so we can have OS
proper contextual menus inter
application and we can either set them
globally or on an item-by-item basis so
depending on when your app needs to do
so again to the end user they have this
is all the right set of tools they have
no idea what's this threaten it so here
I have a contextual menu building it
from a template usually the contextual
menus are a little simple over that all
the nesting in the menus custom
functions right in here and then I just
set it right here to a window event
listener so this one would just
anywhere I clicked inside my application
this was show up but you know I want it
on a specific button your pacific
element you know i just knew where i
attach that event listener to see even
though we get nice things you know fat
arrow functions so all the cool things
you're learning like he refused you know
all draped this is the magic between the
two worlds so i was talking about those
two silos the ipad main silo you got
there in your silo they don't talk to
one another kind like my twins
I have boy-girl twins he is with doc
usually yelling it was emptying the
dishwasher I PC so like us like me and
my life when parents or three I came
between these two the IP see this is the
channel between these two processes
because basically these are kind of sort
of segregating there is a way to
actually call functions within each
other you can but what I have found and
talking with other developers it tends
to get little mystery messy that way
they really do like to sort of keep UI
stuff over here really separation
concerns and stuff that's really sort of
OSE over on the main but a great example
of where that baton handoff would be was
I click on a button over here then I
want to open like a save dialog save
dialogs over in the US side of the world
so I need to tell it ain't go from the
dialog and then the dialogue needs to
tell say might UI oh here's your file
path and oh okay I'm done now do this or
whatever
it's the IPC that allows us to talk back
and forth IPC actually comes in two
flavors it comes in a synchronous
portion version as well as an
asynchronous version so this is the sync
version so pull it in and you know
they're really cryptically named IPC
renderer IPC main usually keep it
straight well
it's between the morning and your
chapters do basically here we were
attaching it to a button to have on my
UI click and then basically send
synchronous this message with that and
over here so this part right here that's
sort of the name of my token I'm sending
over and over in the renderer it says
hey if I get an IPC message with this
basically as the message header then
pull these argit's and do this and then
I can basically send back the return
value now it's all locked up synchronous
we may want something asynchronous very
type is similar hey we're going to send
over and then same idea so depending how
your UI and your interaction but
sometimes you may want to lock something
up until it's done sometimes you may not
or they run so a great place where this
gets used is actually pulling up and
kicking off dialogues so you know we
have some files we're starting to get
more and more file access with our
browser but you know the native alert
dialog in a web browser is on a scale of
1 to 10 and what about of 1 I mean it's
you know it's funny it's actually like
one of the first things you actually
show the in one's done Lina Cordova work
same thing you pull up but you make a
phone gap app you have a JavaScript
alert and this is your index dot HTML a
little arm like oh well that's not nice
so the first thing you do is like you
need a dialog same thing here
how do you give me a dialog well we got
them we actually have several variations
of them so we have a file open and file
save we have a message box which is
really sort of your alert info box we
all said this special alert box
sometimes the naming in github kind of I
love to hit that wayback machine because
Kony's box
I don't fully get I'd love to like how
that one who lost the bet you know an
air box is something you can fire off
very very very very fast in the start of
your application if something went
horribly horribly wrong but but the cool
ones are like the file open so this
basically is where that IPC stuff starts
to having to play again so here we have
a dialogue we're gonna say hey go open
the director dialog boom go do this and
then we're gonna get a nice-looking file
dialog we have a lot of opportunities
with the open so we can actually filter
on the file the directory multiselection
if I want to be need to be able to
create a directory so all these
capabilities you would want in a desktop
application are there I can even you
know show the hidden files it's like up
you know you're writing a text editor oh
yeah that dot did ignore that you
actually need to go at it I can show
that to you because hidden and actually
there's some nice thing I'm windows we
can actually prompt to create so here's
a little more here's a save you know
hide extension a a lot of the things are
all there for us so message boxes these
are really dialog boxes in my world very
similar except now we start to find your
buttons whose default what cancel is
because remember is you start moving in
the desktop world you have to know do
you think about keyboard interaction
accessibility those sorts of things so
when I hit you know escape to cancel who
am I talking to what am i working with
message in detail there are four
variations so an info an error a
question in a nun on the Mac side
they're all the same there really there
is no visual difference between them
Windows actually does something with
those variations so the
pending on my type you know I can get
different icons in there and had her a
little bit of elements of how they
layout now you are not bound to the
default icons you can actually have your
own custom icon your custom image so
basically we have a module in there
called native image tell it where our
little icon is and then we can just pass
that in as an icon so you know your
visual designers crafted a beautiful
application icon and then you can plop
the warning triangle on the corner and
make it look nice and pretty or
something else now I was talking earlier
that that UI layer was all about
chromium we have all of these web
content events that we can listen to and
hook into and start to do something with
so depending on what your application
usually do you know do the cursor change
should I do something
if the dev tools were open do something
did I fail the load did I you know media
started playing plug-in crashed you can
actually run flash inside there just
just so you know if you actually need it
to and you will navigate all these
things these are all the pins and things
you can start to listen into if your
application needs to work with them
alright let's talk about some of the sad
parts of the world debugging because I
know everyone in this room you know
writes flawless code but your co-workers
may not you know how do you handle that
well the renderer process actually we
have chromium's dev tools right there
for us so we have our console log we can
go in look at the HTML why is the CSS
misbehaving what's going on I can go at
it from there
the main process actually is a little
harder because this is a little bit
inside the land of node we actually can
implement and use vs code
code tools its debugging to get in there
and if you are a no person you're
familiar with node inspector you pull
that in and start playing it over on
that end of the world because those two
silos or are truly silos you know you
may be putting console logs over there
but you're not going to see them in the
console log that you would see over on
the renderer side so there is another
extension actually a dev tools extension
called Deb Tron it has some interesting
stuff I used a little bit it didn't
knock my socks off it's kind of like
okay it's there but it the only thing I
would say is it does help a little bit
about some of the IPC communication is
stuff going back and forth that's really
at one part of the world what you're
living in it's two worlds at same time
all right how many people test write
unit tests in more hands more hands fix
that I'm a prototype or a friend of mine
wrote job description read one time in a
toxis I get paid to write spaghetti code
for a living so it's awesome I'm a UX
I'm prote ever it literal is like it's
got to run for 12 people for a usability
study and it never sees the light of day
so but I know in the real world testing
is important they actually have a tool
called spectrum which you can use to
leverage and actually run proper unit
tests with mocha and chai or whatever
and actually begin to test your
application which is probably rather
important especially if you start
thinking about fact this is desktop
application a lot more security starts
to come into play because you have
access to everything in here you know
you can say I'm going to erase your hard
drive you know you a lot of power a lot
of responsibility comes in writing an
electron app and you want to make sure
it's it's working well um real simple
installation boom so let's talk about
building your application we'll get to
some demos at the end
so you need to somehow sort of compile
all these bits into something
distributable something that may go into
the Mac App Store the Windows Store on a
server that looks and smells like a real
application the preferred tool is this
module called electron builder and
really it only takes a little bit of
change to your setup so like it was
mentioning earlier that's why you kind
of throw some stuff in the app folder
like that it's gonna start writing stuff
out to the building distribution folder
it's a very well maintained project as
always that question you should ask
yourself with any sort of open source
tool how well machined is it you know am
I going to be hitting life you know two
months from now when the critical bug
hits and I'm completely in trouble so
it's just nice to have a good maintained
library it will build for all our
platforms it will build for our various
architectures so if you have to deal for
you know packed into 32 bit or 64 back
windows it will do all that for you
basically in that package.json file we
need to update our scripts to basically
tell it to run build what we want to
build for and then we need to define a
whole bunch of properties these are
actually very real document we have to
give an app ID everyone needs an app ID
that's how the world you know thesis so
straight copyrights you know the name
it's going to be what elect version of
electron I want a package in their
category from putting us in the app
store for Mac where it's gonna live what
kind of installer for Windows what I
want to do for Linux how many one should
with their app icons etc etc all start
you I put them all in here those are the
things you started defining here if you
feel like said you ever worked with
Cordova this is sort of the equivalent
of the config dot XML file just they
have to use JSON because ten years ago
so really you know what you just
basically have to point to where that
new starter
is it's all good to go make your app
Thai icons in there
yup you a little further like for the
Mac you know you've probably have opened
DM G's disk images and you've probably
seen something you know really nice like
this you know okay take this icon this
app put it over here in this you know
alias Applications folder message sent
to the Installer but you have to tell it
where this graphic is now big it is and
what those things are and it will create
that dmg for you make a zip and they're
they're your bits
same thing with Windows it will make
your windows installers I know if
anyone's ever tried to make them windows
installer but oh there's so much fun so
really just take a lot of the pain out
of it there are a couple variations on
the two types of windows installers out
there this or not but you get to define
this is the real simple one you can have
a more formal one and you can start to
define sidebar graphics and header
graphics and make make it look you know
like a real software developer knew what
they were doing when they made this
installer it's really nice auto updating
this was a hard part this was actually
more interesting than I thought I almost
kind of feel like they got to the floor
I'm like oh we just got to add it and
move on it is built into electron
however the amount of additional work
with the default electron auto update
system really left my head scratching
because they're not even on top of the
same worlds so for Mac OS is going to
use the system called squirrel dot Mac
which is different than the squirrel for
Windows and wilt Linux actually here
sorry I don't look completely but for
the Mac one to work you got to have your
own server up and running sending back a
JSON file when requested to then send
the update around and all this like I
said I'm a prototype I'm a front-end guy
I'm like what server what was 200
response with what package Oh
No please help me help me
so instead there's a lovely alternative
package out there called electron
updater and there's actually a sort of I
call a third party group its electron
usually and I believe they actually have
written quite a few so that electron
builder tool I mentioned earlier it's
the same group also has done this I also
got an electron forgers talk about a
second this is an alternative to the
electrons built-in updater and the nice
thing is it doesn't worry about the
whole server response sort of stuff so
you just basically drop this in as a
replacement and life is good again so
you pull in their auto update or not
electrons and then you can basically
listen on to various events it goes out
to a URL it asks some stuff and then
check if there's an update not update
download an error so you can have it do
a silent install a prompt install so all
that updating you've seen inside of
really BS code stuff like that it's all
living on this much much simpler than
like standing up your own Heroku
instance and uploading stuff and hoping
you did it right that's sort of thing
so but yeah it is electron usual and
they've also started another project
which I was just playing with toward the
end of the book this thing called
electron forge which is really an
electron CLI it's almost the whole
collection of tools to make all this
even simpler it was just getting off the
ground so I'm like oh we don't want to
rewrite the book and we're already late
so just mention it at the end so that's
the book that's me let me show you some
demos
all right so make a little bigger so
before actually run this thing so here's
the package.json file you can see we're
a little test and got distribution in
there if your keywords and we're dead
dependencies build script type stuff let
me just go ahead and run this oh it's
that's right it moved it that's what I
get for cleaning up before you start
right yes
FDR read you may have noticed that
presentation I just gave you was
electron app a sure that was just
revealed J s that really just dropped in
to the quick start replacing existing
files and was just an electro not so it
literally is that easy to take a web app
and slap it into electron out now I
didn't do anything to desica file no
word things like you know what were the
keyboard you know putting up a proper
menu keyboards and age we do this
eccentric no no that was done but it's a
little as simple as it was
so here's electrum so those little
chrome tools I was talking about right
there
I forgot to pull in the FPC render but
that's okay you know I can pull up my my
dialog box and then you know I can see
what we have down here I can choose a
directory all these things that I want
to assembly processes there's you know
console.log back and forth and this is
all that code I was talking about
through the presentation so pull the P
modules I basically go flying the
document again keeping it vanilla and
you know contextual menus so if I come
back over and ctrl-click you know I get
a real contextual menu inside my HTML
and do something with it
but custom menu there's my custom menu
out so oh and there's a reason why the
buttons are purple look up Rebecca
purple right here are the things back
and forth just what I was showing you to
think I'll just simply put it up inside
the thing inside there over in the main
j/s
here's where I'm creating the window a
little bit of the menus you said that
the menus can get a little larger this
is where some of that file management
loading in would be probably
advantageous
generate the icon custom functions and
that sort of thing so that is you know
kind of the start of electron and here
let me show you what's possible it's
right there
so here's ion generator so we have that
splash screen and then here we have this
application right here this is an
electron application and now in the App
Store it's signing you go that far the
UI actually is the ionic framework so
even I'm taking a mobile framework and
actually pulled into the desktop so I
have the ability to go through here and
the idea is if you've worked with ionic
it comes with a CLI I can never remember
all the parameters and it actually
doesn't do everything that you would
need to set up your ionic application
things like adjusting the manifest.json
file for progressive web app updating
the XML file you were deploying it to a
native mobile app pulling in the various
plugins the Cordova plugins this
actually was I said well let's just play
around with it so I can go through it
start to define my manifest.json over
here come over to Cordova yeah I know
there's no platform start to pulling
things a lot of flying splash screens
things that would do in a Cordova
application yes I know unemployed I can
start having me scrolling lists pulling
in plugins I can pull in lock testing
and eventually have it execute the CLI
in the terminal all my user system so I
don't even paste out like now don't copy
this into a terminal it would actually
run and build my on ik application all
through a GUI so if you have a bunch of
command-line tools lying around you
could actually write a UI making a lot
more friendly a little more safeguards
and actually just use electron to
actually run those headless things for
you and go from there
but that is a brief look at just you
know just the top veneer of what
electron is sort of a sampling of what
the tools it can give you
hard part is you know writing all the
application logic you know just solve
that for you but it really gives you a
nice other solution to take that web app
take that idea out of the browser you
know where you probably had to say to
your boss
oh the browser won't let me do that Oh a
desktop can well now you can
so with that that is electron so yes we
can open up to do some questions if
there are any hey I'm Vijay thanks for
coming to the meetup today I'm the
organizer for JavaScript LA I wanted to
just personally thank you for watching
this video if you found it useful I'd
love for you to subscribe to our Channel
we're slowly but surely making lots of
little video content for you guys to
enjoy and soak up especially if you want
to get better at programming I'd love
for you to be on our slack channel to
over 800 users the link is right here
jeaious join jsj oin if you forget it's
really simple you have questions for
this meetup or you know questions you
didn't get to ask or because you
couldn't make it we'd love to have you
just posted on our slack group so if
you're newbie don't worry it's a good
place to go there's a lot of great
engineers all connected around La in
Orange County so I hope to see you there